[Music]
they are a shameful lot
a motley crew parading around as our
representatives
yet in truth the epitome of people in it
for themselves
i'm not the only one who feels this way
congress's approval rating has polled as
low as 17 percent this year
i'm surprised it's even that high since
this corona virus hit our shores
we've looked at congress for action yet
they're in action their feeble attempt
to come
out and look like they're going to help
us is as transparent and useless
as they are but this week topped even
nancy pelosi
shameless i'm rich and you're not
theater
as she posed eating ice cream in front
of her 24 thousand dollar refrigerator
freezer claiming
that her rose of 13 of pine chocolate
ice cream
was helping her deal with the pandemic
what pandemic there's no pandemic for
people like you nancy
you constantly violate the rules you
pass
the pain and the pleas of working people
fall on
deaf ears as you claim to not understand
why people are against lockdown orders
your cold response
shelter in place is really the answer
really you phony condescending
fraudulent hypocrite as you
the most powerful elected house democrat
pontificate that we simply need to
listen to the science
you march through a salon without a mask
like a queen
immune from any laws or science you
and your ilk violate your own rules so
often
it's clear you believe not only
that you are above the law but also that
the rules serve
no purpose other than to suppress
and defeat us while you and california
governor gavin newsom
shut us down yet selfishly dying at
restaurants
so beyond the reach of people you seek
to suppress
that you're creating an unnecessary
class war admit it
you don't even believe what you're
saying and by the way is it even your
role to say
who should work and who shouldn't
why can't one store be open but not
another as democrats look to crush
small business target costco
home depot and amazon and the big box
companies
they are all thriving small businesses
selling the same items are not allowed
to open but you keep saying
listen to the science what science
where are the numbers that support the
closing of
all restaurants in new york new jersey
and california
when there is only a 1.4 coveted spread
and you keep trying to close schools and
get
more money for the unions yet kids
rarely get it
and they rarely spread it the teachers
who get it get it from home
yet you hypocrites allow social distance
to disappear when so-called
social justice is in your agenda
where is the small business justice
where is the right to the pursuit of
happiness where is the right of the
little man to compete in this country
why is mcdonald's allowed to open but
not my neighborhood burger joint
you say the drive-thru is safe
tell me about the guy who hands me the
french fries through the window
did he touch his hands to his glasses
his apron to the person's hands before
me
was the burger cooked on an open grill
was that man's mask on the whole time
and if he sneezed did the mask flip
off how long have his gloves been on
did he wipe his hands on his pants or
his apron
did he touch his sleeve the one that he
coughed into
who are you kidding but the one who
takes the cake
is andrea ocasio-cortez who at age
30 took the vaccine now i
call it the trump vaccine funny so many
democrats said
they wouldn't take it if it came out of
the trump administration yet
there they are jumping to the head of
the line
we don't have enough vaccines and
there's a shortage of supplies to the
elderly and infirm
yet these federal politicians consider
themselves
vital and are therefore among the first
to have
access to the immunization healthy
members of congress many of them younger
than 40
pushing americans to the curb as they
bully their way to get a vaccine
the same bullies who got a paycheck and
didn't give a damn
about whether you would be getting one
these
selfish politicians getting a vaccine
before all the health care
workers who work 15 hours a day seven
days a week
to make sure that we were safe
my friend a doctor is 73 he spent his
life caring for others
he has a compromised immune system an
upset of his c
t cell balance will prove fatal to him
he's not going to get the vaccine for
months after congress
essential workers which includes the
garbage collectors and the truckers
he is hoping and his family is hoping
he can hang on long enough to get it
now i have an idea aoc you're the one
who talks to big talk about equality
minority justice and injustice you
should be the last in line to get the
vaccine
you guys did nothing for the last six
months but played politics in the run-up
to the presidential election
why weren't you guys protesting with
small business owners
who know in their hearts that they will
not survive another shutdown
who know there's no one fighting for
them
you don't have to be a genius to know
that if lockdowns
actually work they wouldn't have to keep
blocking us down
and you who anoint yourself the savior
of the downtrodden
have you even been trying to get money
to americans
a simple straight bill you condescending
patronizing
holier than holier-than-thou judgmental
self-important phonies
all of you who use our tax dollars to
pay yourselves
while we wait and beg you to get our
money for our families
and now to get a vaccine to survive
after you get the vaccine after you get
paid
while you shovel down 500 meals at the
french laundry in california
when families are waiting in line for
food across
america you're disgusting you're an
embarrassment to the people's house
and now for the big screwing
how do you justify taking money from
america
to give to foreign countries and special
interests during a pandemic
as we come upon the end of tenor
protections
this december 31 with the inability to
work
the inability to get a vaccine and you
arrogant
selfish politicians think that 600
is enough a primer
you work in the house of representatives
it is the people's house
it was built for those who are closest
to the people
you work for us we pay your salary your
staff for your travel for your
junkets you spend our money not yours
and you prefer to spend it now on third
world countries
while we're in a pandemic you want to
give 10 million dollars for gender
programs in
pakistan 1.4 billion
to the asian reassurance initiative act
37 million to make sure the philippine
students
don't play hooky if you can't afford to
take care of americans
but you can take care of other countries
and special
projects of lobbyists then we can't
afford to have
you in the people's house you've proven
that you're disloyal
that your health and your salaries are
more important
than the people who put you in power
naively
you're a disdain for the people you
represent
and it will be your undoing trust me on
that
and that's my open let me know what you
think on my facebook and twitter
hashtag judge janine if you like my
opens
you're going to love my new book don't
lie to me it's available
for order at all bookstores and at
judgejanine.store